Stitch pattern using DesignaKnit
with your machine is accomplished
by sending data from your computer
to the carriage, instructing the carriage
to select and position needles.
Before you fast forward, please hang
in there with me for just a moment.
It's important that you understand this.
In general, stitch patterning is accomplished
by the position of the needles
and how they pass through the channels
under the carriage.
The channels are controlled
by the cam lever.
The red line in this image indicates
the path that the needle butts take.
Notice how the levers change
the configuration of the channel,
therefore, the path
the needle butts travel.
As the needle butts are directed
through the channel, the needles
are positioned to form stitches.
Each needle will either knit, slip, tuck,
or knit with a different yarn.
Please remove your carriage, turn it over,
hold it securely, shift the cam lever,
and observe what happens.
In the following exercises,
we will explore the different stitch
patterns available on your machine
and the steps for accomplishing them.
But remember, it's DesignaKnit, sending
signals to the carriage that determines
which needles pass
through the path under the carriage,
and it's the cam lever that determines
the configuration of the path
and which stitch type is formed.